we are learning at least three more
people accused of making mass shooting
threats are under arrest this morning in
the weeks after the deadly shootings in
Gilroy California El Paso Texas and
Dayton Ohio police have broken up
alleged plots in several states
including Connecticut Florida Ohio
Missouri Illinois and Washington our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
joins us with more on why this is
happening
Trika why are more people reaching out
to police now well Gail authorities
simply believe that people are becoming
less hesitant to report concerning
behavior so more active shooter
situations are being prevented they are
making it clear that any threat will be
taken seriously newly released body cam
video shows a 15 year old being
handcuffed in Florida after posting on
an online video game under a fake name
that he vowed to bring his father's m15
assault rifle to school and kill seven
people at a minimum his mother insist it
was a joke but her son is still facing a
felony charge an Indiana 38 year old
truck driver Thomas Matthew McVicker is
in custody after a friend reported him
for allegedly planning to carry out a
mass shooting at a Memphis church and
use his knife to slit a pastor's throat
a possible national tragedy you know was
avoided because this young lady did the
right thing McVicar allegedly texted his
friend I think I'm just gonna kill some
people on the street and get away with
it then kill myself according to court
papers mcvickers mother confirmed her
son is being treated for schizophrenia
and that he owns a handgun someone who's
already thinking about it will
accelerate those plans when they see the
one the one before that and that's why
this appears to be a contagion NYPD
Deputy Commissioner of intelligence and
counterterrorism John Miller says in
most cases suspects will signal they
might be planning something the patterns
are fairly clear if people learn what
they are and have
to step forward and say I'm going to
report this we're going to have fewer of
these Miller says it usually takes three
or four stressors in someone's life like
a breakup losing a job trouble at school
or losing a home for someone to start
sending those warning signals if a
person or signals rather in person or
online the FBI does have a 24-hour
hotline to track down online threats it
really comes down to this guys if you
see something say something report it to
your local police all the experts say
that normally there are clues we just
really have to pay attention and know
what we're looking for yeah and you
can't be making jokes about guys killing
not at all Jericka thanks